the day before things got really crazy I
like went to Target and you know to get
like supplies and stuff and while I was
there I was like I should get like I
mean obviously so I quit okay this is no
no no okay so number one this is kind of
cool oh my god did you make something
awesome no way yeah it's not finished
yeah crap right now you did that you
guys it's amazing okay okay okay but I'm
in like the Lego aisle at Target and I
swear to god this is true this is not
like something that got sent to me or
anything and I like did you just buy
your god don't get recognized in to
checkout line cuz how lame am i but I
think I'm just buying the merchandise
for myself look look look it's her bed
uh what because you don't have kids
right this is just you hanging out with
your [ __ ] being a winner supportive of
art obviously that's amazing
well did no one recognized you no even
if it should recognize me I swear to god
they would probably be like no I mean it
looks like her but it can't be her
because I'm quite rooms
you wouldn't be buying her own
merchandise like an actual serial killer
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going